I was not worried about a loss of
privacy I was worried about a loss of a
public space where people's private
lives weren't always being shoved in
your face and technology has made that a
lot worse as far as I can tell I'm
assaulted by other people's private
lives and the whole new set of ways
I cannot shop for groceries without
getting their private conversations but
that's that's not what people mean when
they talk about a loss of privacy so I
had a very very clear notion of here's a
public space wouldn't it be nice to only
get a composed polite or even rude but
some some sort of like acknowledgement
that we're in a public place that we're
not just having our own private lives
and there are some other people having
their private lives floating around but
there's some collective notion of like
put yourself together a little bit be
show that tiny bit of respect for the
other human beings around you and not
broadcast your private life in that
respect and if you if you look at
privacy which I felt was the problem I I
felt like this obsession with privacy I
thought the this you know we live in a
the growth of the private sector and the
shrinkage of the public sector even make
a little pun like that you know it's a
this is a privatized world all of that
has gotten a little worse and at a
certain point I realized you know I
wrote that thing during the the Clinton
Lewinsky misery and felt like all of the
commentators had it dead wrong it was
not about Kens stars exposing you know
Bill and Monica's private life I thought
well for God's sake he's the president I
mean what expectation of privacy what I
was what I was offended by was I don't
want to
about these guys you know I don't want
to hear about semen on a dress it's like
you know for God's sake just you know
excuse me please I mean either they're
plenty of place where I'd love to hear
about semen on dresses but not really
you know got coming out of the White
House that inversion where it's where
the privacy loss had to do with
something being made public rather than
being inflicted on me rather than my
private stuff being I don't care you
know I really don't care if people poke
around and my stuff if I never know
about it I had I'm a writer I have an
exhibitionist streak i betray my own
privacy all the time I published all
sorts of private facts about myself and
not just myself but my friends and my
family so I'm not worried about that but
a certain point that sense of assault by
other people's you know stained
underwear when you're just trying to
like walk down a sidewalk or sit in a
theater or something I realized the best
way to manage that was to take out my
own cell phone and start talking so you
know we can't beat them join them